to washington now president biden is
accused of making serious errors in the
hurried evacuation from afghanistan but
he insists the final airlift of
americans and afghan allies
was a success the president repeated his
side of the story in a defiant address
to the nation yesterday and as ouija
zhang reports mr biden said this was the
right time to end america's longest war
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
president biden praised the u.s military
for its final mission in afghanistan
calling the airlift of more than 120
thousand people an extraordinary success
but more than 100 u.s citizens are still
trying to evacuate even though the
president made this promise two weeks
ago if there's american citizens left
we're going to stay to get them all out
administration officials said since then
growing threats in kabul from isis-k
changed the timeline pointing to a
suicide bombing that killed 13 service
members last week president biden also
said his decision to leave afghanistan
serves another purpose this decision
about afghanistan
is not just about afghanistan
it's about ending an era
of major military operations
to remake other countries
that declaration helps to define
president biden's foreign policy agenda
he says the world is changing so he
wants to focus on new threats like
competition from china and aggression
from russia like cyber attacks and its
nuclear ambition vlad
all right we did thank you very much